[MUSIC PLAYING]
DANIEL BARRETO: Haystack
TV started in 2013
as a startup coming out of
Stanford StartX Accelerator.
We were frustrated with
how news was getting out,
because every time
we turn on the TV,
we had to watch the same
news as everybody else.
Our elevator pitch
here at Haystack TV
is that we enable
people to watch
the news that they care about.
One of the decisions we had
to make at the beginning
was what platform to start with.
As a small startup,
we needed a platform
that would allow us
to iterate quickly.
We got that with Android.
ISH HARSHAWAT: The
team at Haystack TV
really loves working
with Android.
The documentation is really
clear and easy to use.
It can be a lot of fun
to program for Android.
DANIEL BARRETO: Our
users wanted to watch
the news in their living
rooms, in their TVs.
And there wasn't a platform
out there for them to do that.
ISH HARSHAWAT: A lot of
the smart TVs to date
have been pretty
proprietary closed
systems that have been hard for
developers like us to access.
With Android TV, we were
able to finally open
the door into the living room.
Even though a developer can
easily take their mobile app
and throw it on Android TV,
what works really well we found,
was to actually design an
Android TV first experience.
Developing for Android
TV was super fast.
We literally did it two weeks.
DANIEL BARRETO: We've
seen amazing results
after integrating with
Android TV and Chromecast.
Originally, our
mobile users were
spending an average
of 40 minutes
per week watching the news.
Now we've actually doubled that.
Our growth trajectory is
really strong right now.
We've managed to grow
at 40% month over month
since we started.
And a big part of that is
the integration with the TVs.
It's a new beta testing
feature that Android released.
It allowed us to reach our
early beta and alpha testers.
And it also allowed us to
integrate with Google+,
so that we can reach different
communities of early adopters.
That was extremely
powerful for us.
A small startup like ours is
now able to make a big impact
with just six people, reaching
out to millions of users.
And a lot of it is thanks
to the tools and platform
that we have with Google.